what i love about number five is that
he's an old guy
in a young boy's body what i probably
need to start wording that better
but i don't think that anyone can deny
that aidan gallagher completely nails
the complexities of the time traveling
character
but what are his hopes his dreams well
throughout this video we're going to be
giving you the lowdown on 5
including his backstory and powers
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out both seasons of the umbrella
academy
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now we'll also be talking about some
spoilers in the comics too
searches his time at the temps and also
a twist that hasn't been revealed yet
but i will give you a heads up just
before we get into that
anyway with that out of the way this is
the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition aka youtube's
number two
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
five was born on october 1st
1989. in umbrella academy law
this is a special day as it signals the
arrival of 43 children
all blessed with amazing abilities vive
is no exception to this
and the character is able to dissolve
and reform his own matter at will
this gives him the ability to not only
teleport but it also allows him to move
backwards and forwards through time
five can sometimes use this on those
around him and because of his powers he
was able to journey back to the 60s with
the rest of his family
he also at one point switched out a
criminal's gun with a stapler
showing that he may possess the ability
to move objects too
though he rarely uses this because 5 is
actually 58
he's managed to pick up a wealth of
skills over his lifetime
and these have molded him into a master
combatant
five is a skilled assassin that uses his
knowledge of warfare to easily dispatch
his foes
and because of this he's not someone
that you want to trifle with
so basically to sum it up five is
nightcrawler from the x-men
with the ability to time travel now
whilst this temporal powers
sound like a really cool thing to have
with them comes several consequences
and after every jump through time five
creates an alternate reality
that tends to lead to the apocalypse in
addition to this
due to his inability to fully control
his chronokinesis
rather than moving through time time
moved through five
and thus he ended up becoming trapped in
his younger body which he's remained in
since jumping to 2019
now in the comics five doesn't age it
all and he remains
stuck in his ten-year-old body and just
doesn't grow
in the graphic novel it's revealed that
because he was their greatest assassin
the temps actually experimented on him
and made it so that he wouldn't age
this is why when he goes back to his
younger self he just doesn't grow up
however i think due to aiden gallagher
aging more and more as the seasons go on
the show will have him growing up once
more and aging is normal with him
essentially just restarting his life in
my opinion this is why the
experimentation
hasn't been mentioned in the show but
let me know below if you disagree
now in addition to this the temps also
took every major killer in history
placed their dna into five and this is
why he never feels any remorse or guilt
over his killings
that's pretty much the lowdown on the
character and though he's the longest
living of the hargreaves siblings
we still don't know that much about him
when five was young
he was quite arrogant with his powers
and he ignored the warnings of his
father who instructed him not to jump
through time until he knew what he was
doing
when testing his abilities five found
that he could jump ahead
and he pushed this to the limit by
making several leaps however the
character jumped too far ahead
and found himself caught on the other
side of the apocalypse
five was unable to jump back and thus
became stuck there
wandering the wasteland for decades now
with the comics comes several caveats
and because five did not grow up with
the rest of the academy
he did not eventually leave them and
form his own identity
thus whilst the other members of the
group shed their numbers in favor of
their actual names
five became stuck with his and therefore
still done
the moniker number five though we know
what happened to him
to the other members of the group five
appeared as a missing person
and he could be seen as instrumental in
the rest of the family deciding to leave
the academy
this is because upon his disappearance
so reginald
actually remarked that his absence was
no great loss and thus the academy
likely saw themselves in the same light
they slowly moved out of their childhood
home
and onto bigger and better things whilst
five became lost to time
five returned and explained that he'd
managed to travel back in time
however vania did not believe him and
instead thought that time travel had
just messed with his mind
initially no one took his word until the
thames commission arrived
and through this we learned the truth
about what really happened to him
it turns out that five spent the
majority of his life wandering the
wasteland of armageddon
and at this point he came across a
mannequin named dolores
whom the character fell in love with
let's be honest
we've all woken up to worse and slowly
this
sent him slightly insane five even
treated dolores like she was a real
person
and became overly protective of her upon
joining the temps he left dolores behind
but he did visit her in a department
store saying his goodbyes
and also telling a worker to pick
something nice for her to wear
i'm not crying you're crying now as
we've mentioned
five was recruited by the temps and he
was offered the deal of working for them
for five years in exchange for being
able to retire to a time
that is hot desired quickly he rose
through the ranks
and became one of their best assassins
completing job after job with these
due to his abilities to appear and
seemingly disappear at random
we learned that 5 actually killed lyla's
parents and under the direction of the
handler he was chosen to assassinate jfk
it's at this time that he learned of the
apocalypse and decided to attempt to
avert it in order to save his family
now a lot of people have wondered why
five actually did this
especially because he hadn't seen his
family for years
and due to his personality he was pretty
much a sociopath
well this is actually hinting that in
the comics
now this is a big spoiler for five's
origins so if you don't wanna know
anything then i suggest you pause the
video
and travel 30 seconds into the future in
order to miss out this big
spoiler are you still here good that
means you haven't ruined the timeline
and you get to learn the secrets so in
the comics it's revealed by carmichael
that five's mother
actually gave birth to twins now though
that might be a big shock to you
and it could potentially leave room for
an evil version of five down the line
we learned that five's twin is actually
just luther
i'll give my thoughts on how this might
be changed in the show later
but that's an important thing to bear in
mind now upon returning to 2019
they tried to trace back the source of
doomsday and after an investigation
they discovered the root of the problem
vonye
she was the one responsible for ruining
the world and though the academy
initially tried to lock her away
they realized that what they actually
needed to do was shower her with
kindness and love
oh the group showed up to calm it down
but she ended up going full supervillain
and this destroyed the moon and sent an
asteroid hurtling towards the planet
allison was able to sedate vonye and
five with his family travel back to the
60s
unfortunately due to still not having
proper control of his powers
the family were dropped at several
points throughout the decade and five
himself was transported to 1963.
here he discovered that there was
another apocalypse once more caused by
vanier
it's revealed that the fbi had taken her
in for questioning after believing she
was a russian spy
and during torture she went into full
overdrive triggered by her memories of a
childhood
she set off a blast at their
headquarters and this destroyed a large
section of it
this just so happened to take place as
jfk's motorcade was passing
and thus he suspected that the russians
had committed a terrorist act
and declared war on the country hazel
arrived to help five avert this
and together the two travelled back to a
time before the apocalypse
unfortunately hazel was killed by the
swedes
but five was able to unite his family
it's at this point that he was
approached by the handler
who gave him the time and place of a
meeting between the board of the thames
commission
in exchange for killing them the handler
promised to avert the apocalypse
and give them a temp briefcase which
would allow them to return back to 2019.
thus five carried out the mission
however the handler tricked him
and only gave the character 90 minutes
to unite his family and returned back to
the tens
five realized that there was a version
of himself in the past that two
possessed a briefcase
and thus he went and met him this was
the five that we actually saw back in
season one
just before he jumped across time in
space five said that he would give him
the correct calculations to remain in
his older body
in exchange for the briefcase and the
two made a deal however
both as paranoid as the other they ended
up fighting and the younger five jumped
through the portal which also destroyed
the brick case
now though we don't know what happened
to him this created another alternate
timeline in which there was a version of
the first season that had an older five
rather than the one stuck in his younger
body now at the end of the season
five and co not only stopped the temps
commission but also bonya from wreaking
havoc on the planet
five in the umbrella academy are almost
killed by the handler
but five remembers advice given to him
by reginald
this was to travel back in minutes
rather than decades
and he managed to go back to before her
arrival and stop a dead in her tracks
i'm not sure if this creates an
alternate timeline too but
if it does then that means that there's
a universe where the hargreaves were all
killed at this point
and season three was cancelled now after
the new director of the temps
herb arrives he says he can stop the
apocalypse in the future
and gives them a briefcase to return to
2019
now though they keep their end of the
bargain it becomes a situation of be
careful what you wish for
as upon traveling back to 2019 they find
that reginald selected other children to
be part of the academy
and this is shown in the sparrow academy
now we've already done a full breakdown
of the members of this group
which you should definitely check out if
you want to know more they're basically
the same as the current academy power
wise
and there's an opposite to luther
allison and pretty much
every member has someone in this group
that's the same because of this
i actually think that this box dude
might be fives opposite
and it is possible just in the way that
five was able to jump through time
that this character was able to jump
through dimensions
if he was then it would make sense that
there would exist a realm in which
everyone was a cube
and this character may have ended up
trapped in this form upon attempting to
jump back
similar to how five became trapped in
his younger body either that or he went
so far ahead in the future that
humans had transferred their
consciousness to boxes because
let's face it be there or be square
the show might also do a change up and
he may be the big twist that we talked
about earlier in the video that i can't
ruin here
just in case you you're one of those
people that time traveled ahead
you know what i'm talking about anyway
if you did watch that bit and yeah let
me know below
anyway there's definitely a lot that
could be taken from this cube guy
and i can't wait to see what
interactions he and 5 have in the future
anyway that's everything you need to
know about 5 and the 101 and the
character
obviously i'd of course love to hear
your thoughts on 5 and if you agree with
my theories or have any of your own
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you want something else to
watch after this then check out our
breakdown of sir reginald hargreaves
which is going to be linked at the end
we go over the big bad dad of the
umbrella academy
including his origins and powers so it's
definitely worth checking out
if you want to have a good time now
don't forget every month on the 15th we
give away free blu-rays
and all you have to do to be with a
chance of winning the mcu infinity saga
box set is leave a like and subscribe
with notifications on
if you want to support the channel and
get see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
to say